[Música]
hablamos con nuestra segunda invitada
del día el gobierno de El Salvador el
traslado del 24 de febrero a miles de
los más de 64 mil supuestos pandilleros
que ha restado desde el año pasado a la
mega cárcel que construyó en su guerra
declarada contra las pandillas un centro
con capacidad para 40.000 personas
considerado además el más grande de
América y que promete cerrar ese círculo
de crimen en el país tras cinco
renovaciones de un estado de emergencia
con el que el gobierno ha realizado
arrestos masivos a los que atribuye una
dramática caída de asesinatos sin
embargo investigadores de Nueva York que
consideran que puede haber corrupción de
por medio Cuáles son las consecuencias y
qué tan efectivas son las medidas de
bukele en el tiempo lo analizamos con su
chiste de Chávez el periodista de la
revista factum Gracias por estar en
directo a América
Hola Muy buenos días Ángela mucho gusto
y Bueno gracias por la invitación No ni
más faltaba y mire el departamento de
justicia de Estados Unidos reveló que la
fiscalía de Nueva York adelanta una
investigación a 13 líderes de la Mara
Salvatrucha en esa investigación señala
a dos altos funcionarios de bukele de
haber negociado con ese grupo criminal
para reducir los homicidios a cambio de
beneficios entre 2019 y 2021 qué es lo
que se sabe de esto
bueno se conoce nada más lo que se ha
revelado a través de de esta publicación
Bueno sí de esta de esta publicación de
esta acusación pero digamos no es la
primera vez que se conoce de este
negociaciones entre el gobierno de
bukele y las pandillas algunos medios
independientes del país ya venían
informando de esto desde hace ya algún
tiempo
esto ya se había revelado pero es
importante que ahora quede sentado en un
documento judicial de un país extranjero
no decir en El Salvador al menos no es
una novedad conocer acerca de estos
pactos para reducción de homicidios
que este fueron mucho antes del régimen
de excepción no de la vigencia del
régimen de excepción bueno eso como
mínimo plantea una duda sobre esta
política que ha sido catalogada como muy
exitosa dentro del país de nayib bukele
Pero hay varios elementos por ejemplo se
ha disparado la población carcelaria si
bien esta medida de restos ma sivos le
da bukele una gran popularidad y a la
ciudadanía una sensación de mayor
seguridad en el mediano y en el largo
plazo usted Cuál es Cuáles cree que
serán los efectos de esta política de
mano dura cuánto pasarán los reos en la
cárcel Y cómo garantizar que no van a
delinquir en las prisiones
claro digamos hay muchas preguntas que
también desde la población nos estamos
haciendo como Cuál es la sostenibilidad
de este tipo de medidas en el tiempo no
ha habido una serie de reformas al
sistema judicial al al sistema del
proceso judicial para poder garantizar
que estas personas puedan estar más
tiempo en en prisión no es decir una de
las más recientes
implica
alargar el plazo máximo de detención el
peso máximo de detención en el en el
Salvador a era para delitos graves para
delitos considerados graves era un
máximo de 24 meses decir los jueces
Tenían un plazo máximo de 24 meses para
resolver la situación jurídica de una
persona
y ahora lo han alargado por un año más o
sea esto le da digamos el gobierno tres
años para mantener a una persona
detenida sin resolver de su situación
jurídica sin decirle si esta persona
o no es culpable Sin que vea un tribunal
de Justicia no y muchas de esas personas
pues fueron capturadas de manera
arbitraria hay más de cuatro mil
denuncias de arrestos arbitrarios
digamos de los que se conocen de las
personas que han logrado acudir alguna
organización de la sociedad civil para
denunciar esta situación bueno es que
justamente las organizaciones de
Derechos Humanos usted lo dice
argumentan que personas inocentes se han
visto involucradas en esta política
incluidos al menos dos docenas que han
fallecido dentro de estas redadas
policiales
Cuál es la esperanza para estas personas
con esta situación que usted nos Comenta
Porque además esto lo que hace es
fortalecer la crítica de Derechos
Humanos contra la política de bukele
Sí a ver No no es un tema fácil
realmente Porque si uno visita las
comunidades que fueron durante años
golpeadas por la delincuencia por la
presencia de pandillas y por eso mismo
son comunidades altamente estigmatizadas
en la narrativa oficial pues las
personas Sí están viviendo con más
tranquilidad eso es innegable incluso
los familiares de personas que están
detenidas
aún teniendo a sus familiares detenido y
digamos reclamando el hecho de que sus
familiares inocente Ellos dicen nosotros
estamos a favor de que se hagan este
tipo de arrestos
porque porque sí ha dado una digamos un
respiro a estas comunidades pero este
digamos es no hay una una buena
Esperanza para para muchas de estas
personas no ha existido digamos una
información pública de parte del
gobierno que que oficialice siquiera el
número total de detenidos mucho menos se
ha informado de las personas que han
fallecido al interior de las prisiones
que ya rondan los noventa según los
cálculos de organizaciones de la
sociedad civil e incluso personas que
han fallecido sin que sus parientes
fueran notificados y que han debido
encontrar a sus parientes hasta dos
meses después enterrados en fosas
comunes es decir una persona que estaba
bajo custodia del Estado
fallece bajo custodia del estado y la
familia no es informada y tienen que ir
a ubicarlo a una fosa común Entonces
digamos las perspectivas no son muy
alentadoras al menos para la gente que
está en prisión a pesar de esta
tranquilidad o aparente tranquilidad que
están viviendo en las comunidades Es que
uno se pregunta A qué costo viene esta
sensación de calma para bukele los
presuntos criminales no son sujetos de
derecho no Cuál es el límite y cuál es
el tratamiento que debe recibir un reo
en El Salvador o en cualquier parte
porque es que la promesa de la Mega
cárcel viene con promesas de menos
comida no tener colchones trabajos
forzados etcétera etcétera
Y eso sí Y bueno si a eso también le
pueden Añadir que a la mega cárcel se
anuncia más o menos un mes después o
menos de un mes después de la entrada en
vigencia del régimen de excepción que ya
no es decepción no porque ya tenemos
once meses con esos ha tenido once
prórrogas sucesivas de parte de la
asamblea legislativa y fue hasta junio
es decir como más o menos tres cuatro
meses después en junio del año pasado
tres o cuatro meses después de su
anuncio me refiero que
en alguna comunidad pues se da se dan
cuenta salió a la a la luz pública que
si ya se estaba construyendo esta esta
prisión pero no ha existido digamos
ningún tipo de transparentación de los
contratos las empresas que al final pues
es una empresa que ya había sido
beneficiada con otros contratos de
algunos proyectos muy importantes y muy
claves para el gobierno Como por ejemplo
el hospital El Salvador decir Digamos si
uno hace un análisis de toda la de toda
la cadena de de de aristas que puede
tener el tema de el régimen de excepción
tanto de la violaciones de Derechos
Humanos como hasta el tema de contratos
Pues el manejo ha sido muy opaco
Ya se nos acaba el tiempo pero quisiera
hacerle la última pregunta muy
rápidamente además es que hay mucha
espectacularidad en los videos oficiales
que promocionan esta mega cárcel no se
muestra a los presos corriendo
semidesnudos descalzos con la cabeza
gacha Usted cree que estas medidas
sirven para desincentivar al crimen
organizado
yo no creo que de sin sentido el crimen
organizado En definitiva sí le ayuda a
la narrativa de mostrar fuerza de parte
del gobierno no y hay mucha gente tiene
mucho apoyo el presidente tiene mucho
apoyo pero no creo que que lo desactive
ese tipo de imágenes ya las habíamos
visto desde hace
15 16 años cuando fue la implementación
del primer plan mano dura acá en el país
no y las pandillas al contrario no
dejaron de crecer pues viene el suchito
y Chávez el periodista de la revista
factum Gracias a ustedes por entregarnos
su visión del asunto y sobre todo su
análisis bueno Muchas gracias por la
invitación y a nuestros televidentes
sigan con nosotros solo unos segundos y
ya regresamos con más titulares en
directo a América
[Música]